I want to talk about consent today which
means I'm gonna be talking about sex so
if you're not ready to hear me
family-friendly Charlie talking about
sex
warning sex in my lifetime I have had a
grand total of two sexual partners I
lost my virginity when I was 21 and it's
kind of surprising to me these days how
little those quantifiers actually matter
to me back in school however my self
perceived sexual inadequacy seemed like
the most shameful thing in the world
like nothing was more terrifying to me
than the idea of one of my school
friends asking me how I had gotten with
a girl and honestly when they did ask me
the few times they did I just lied which
makes me feel like they probably were
just lying as well in hindsight though
I'm very glad that I didn't brush into
anything because I think it helped me to
learn the importance of you know not
rushing in my experience taking the time
to really get to know the person that
you live and what they like makes the
whole sex thing much more enjoyable and
it's also just a really great way to
make sure that the person that you live
really wants to be there too and that is
what consent is it's about making a
positive decision that you and the
person that you live both definitely
want to have sex together and for me
personally having that mutual consent is
completely vital if there's ever any
doubt in my mind that the person I live
doesn't want to be there with me I stop
and I talk to them about it it kinda
ruins the flow yeah but it's the right
thing to do and it's something I think
about every single time and with them
too because just because someone says
yes the first time doesn't automatically
make it yes every other time when I was
in school sex was talked about like it
was some kind of trophy like it was
something you had to get to win approval
but really it's something you have to
get approval for from two people from
yourself and from the person that you're
with if you don't want to have sex and
you're being pressured into doing it
it's horrible
be that through your peers making you
feel bad because you're still a virgin
or be it through you making your partner
feel bad because they aren't up for it
everybody always has a choice about how
far they want to go and what they feel
comfortable with you can't force someone
into doing it and you can't pressure
someone into doing it until they give in
even if the person that you're with says
no then you stop and even if they don't
say no even if they just give the
impression that they're not in the mood
ie their body language they stop kissing
you they just don't want to be held then
you stop okay
in the eyes of the law that is exactly
the same as them saying no and if the
person that you have says no in any of
those ways and you go ahead and have sex
with them anyway that's rape that's what
rape is and if you charge with it you
can go to prison you could get put on
the sex offenders register and it would
likely seriously mess up your future I
am assuming you don't want that when
you're in the mood and your partner
isn't yes it can be very frustrating but
in my experience there is nothing better
than being with someone who you know
definitely wants to be there with you
sex is great but it is so much greater
when you can be giving as much pleasure
as you getting in summary Charlie's sexy
advice is be safe be smart be with
someone who you know wants to be with
you every single time don't do anything
illegal just to be safe and have lots of
fun because sex is great and that's my
official statement bye you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool okay if you need any more
information about relationships about
consent or abuse the best thing you can
do is seek out professional help and
advice from qualified sources click here
to visit in the know for more
information and I'll put a link in the
description as well thank you so much
for watching and I really hope this
helps